okay let's start with your Gun Violence
update I know we're going back and forth
about do I want to do daily updates on
gun violence and I haven't really made a
full decision yet there's some people
who say do it weekly others who like the
idea of doing it daily but today we have
sort of a major milestone number that I
do want to tell you about on October
10th which was a couple weeks ago just
over two weeks ago I came to you and I
said we had this major shooting in Las
Vegas at the beginning of October and I
believe it's 58 people who were shot
dead biggest mass shooting in American
history but as of October 10th we had
seen more than 200 people shot dead
since the Las Vegas shooting and I
pointed out as I've said before mass
shootings are horribly tragic but way
more deaths are coming in the single and
double homicide incidents individual
shooting incidents and these are all
just as tragic and statistically much
more likely than the mass shootings the
numbers since October 10 have even
further exploded since the Las Vegas
shooting at the beginning of this month
more than 800 people have now been shot
to death in the United States including
children I've mentioned it before I'll
mention it again
gun violence archive.org collects this
data they catalogue the data they link
to articles and reports about each
individual incident and the numbers are
staggering
since the Las Vegas shooting 2738 people
have been shot almost 3000 and 840 of
them have been killed no national
spotlight local articles here and there
but this is the epidemic one victim was
just two months old killed when her
father was allegedly unloading a gun and
it went off shooting a two month old
baby in the head and I want to tell you
that tomorrow on the Friday show when we
do audience questions I received a
question David how do we prevent mass
shootings and how do we prevent gun
deaths and those are related but
different questions and I'm going to go
into some more detail tomorrow I don't
want to do the entire segment now
what actually should we do and as a
preview you will very often hear from
the more guns in more places under any
circumstances we can imagine people the
Second Amendment fetishists they will
point to any one suggestion for
decreasing some kind of gun deaths
whether it's suicides single and double
homicides or mass shootings they'll say
that won't work because here's a whole
bunch of examples where that wouldn't
make a difference and we can't fall for
that okay if we can make changes that
would reduce one element of the types of
gun deaths that we're seeing well then
we should consider doing that in
addition to other things and it's
totally fallacious logically to say just
because strategy a won't stop all gun
deaths then we shouldn't consider it at
all suicides with guns single homicides
with guns and mass shootings with guns
obviously if it's a shooting its with
guns if that was kind of redundant they
are all different and thus you are going
to need different strategies in order to
prevent those incidents from taking
place but we'll dig into that more
tomorrow